very cool hey guys
dolly suppose you're wondering why I
called this meeting so we're gonna do
this very quickly because we don't have
a lot of time I don't want to get to the
meat of things which water is this
year's your mind that is yours as some
of you may know Steve Hayes of the
Weekly Standard is left town for a year
to live in Spain and so I needed another
cheese head to hang out with tonight
I picked this guy and and as Arthur
Brooks is leaving the American
Enterprise Institute as president I
thought we could really use another
physical trainer so we had him come here
so anyway I'll spare you all the
promotional plugs for my book I will
spare you all that sort of throat
clearing and as Henry the eighth's said
to each of his wives I won't keep you
long so and I don't he doesn't need any
introduction so oh so I understand
election season midterms are coming up
you're going around for understandable
reasons touting how great the economy is
doing crediting it to the tax bill and
other things and pulling back
regulations let's just stipulate for the
sake of argument that the economy is
doing great and that you deserve all of
the credit okay let's just stipulate
how's democracy doing it's resilient
it's the best system except for all the
other systems right it's that that's the
Churchill line I had to confess to him
in the room back there that I love his
book I just haven't read it yet
and I think democracy is in the 21st
century era facing new challenges that
it had not had before you have illiberal
ism on the rise in parts of the world
you have a rival model in China that
that is that is you know tantalizing to
some and then you have our own
challenges with relativism on the rise
21st century technology and the ability
to monetize division and as you say
tribalism or identity politics and those
are really big challenges for democracy
it's the best system but we have to
continue to win these debates and we're
in one right now and I feel good about
winning it but we've got to get on with
winning it so one of my arguments would
be that the way you win these debates is
by first and foremost teaching people
that debate is important yeah but you
and I both came up in Washington around
the same time as twenty-something policy
gnomes at think tanks yeah say I stayed
true to my roots you you strayed a bit
it's a disappointment to a lot of us but
it seems to me that on the right in
particular but also you know for lots of
liberals in the 1990s there was a it was
it was agreed that arguments were
important to have yeah and we kind of
have lost that why have we lost this
idea that it instead of it's simply you
know anything is worth doing if it
results in drinking the tears of the
enemy right and my favorite New Yorker
cartoon has two dogs drinking martinis
at a bar and one dog says to the other
you know it's not good enough that dogs
succeed cats must also fail right and it
seems to me that so much of our politics
right now is more about cats must also
fail then dogs must succeed why how did
we get that's a really good question so
that's what I wish I had a really good
answer for what I don't I know book you
can read it gives you part of me that's
so so
that's why I'm excited about really
because I'm looking for the answer so
maybe you could up that's a great
question in in the way I look at this is
you know you you think when we came of
age the Cold War was dying and when we
won and we had classical liberalism we
all grew up in the age of Reagan we read
Hayek and Mises and Friedman and the
Chicago School and and we the Nerds HDA
and Locke and all this stuff nerds like
you and I did write the conservative
movement yes a conservative movement was
that and with little skirmishes between
what we called neo cons and Paleo cons
but but we all had the same foundation
now we've got this
we have zero-sum game thinking and
what's unfortunately is we've always
thought that the zero-sum game my game
comes your loss necessarily so and it's
zero-sum we always thought that was an
economic argument that we sort of had
won now we're relitigated it on trade
and everything else but it's it's it's
it's it slipped into the rest of society
and that's the point I think the rise of
relativism on top of that in the old
days like the 90s
I thought identity politics was an
alinsky tool that the left used to
basically get their base going not to
get a majority of the country but just
to sort of get their base go that's what
we used to think of it and so we sort of
thought we won this that's over with
they do that we don't because we believe
in aspirational inclusive you know
politics well here we are now and both
sides use it we used to talk about
Western civilization which to us meant
these classical liberal ideas now the
blood and soil guys have sort of
hijacked the term right so we are back
to zero sum game thinking identity
politics being practiced at twenty with
with that with 21st century technology a
devastating effect that both sides now
use and so we get to go back and read
litigate Andry win these fights again
which we took for granted that we won as
conservatives so not only do in to win
it on our side way to win it for
majority the country so I see relativism
and technology as the accelerant that is
now thrown in our
face that we're gonna go back and we
regally to get these old lessons that
make sense now it makes sense I mean and
you know the Ronald Reagan like to say
we're never more than one generation
away from tyranny as we're not born it's
right with liberty in our blood we have
to fight for it right
or as Hana and said every generation
Western civilization is invaded by
barbarians we call them children yeah
which means that we actually have to
teach children and citizens right that's
right so that process of teaching
children not to be barbarians which
we've had various degrees of success at
the Goldberg household is that starts in
the first civilization which we're born
in which is actually the family right
and it seems to me and part of my
argument would be that so many the
problems that we have in Washington are
downstream of the deeper problems that
we have the breakdown of the family the
breakdown of civil society and you know
if people keep asking me what my public
policy solutions are and I don't have a
lot but one of them is push things down
to the most level level possible
yeah I know you you're sympathetic with
that how was it that project yeah we
Catholics call subsidiarity it's a
beautiful term that no one understands
it is this is why my big one of my big
pushes in in my current location has
been civil society and trying to elbow
out like we're underneath the basketball
trying to get some space for the rebound
space for civil society between the
person and her government I'm told you
wrote about life of Julia in your book I
wrote about in the book I wrote in 2013
that is the progressive system right
which squeezes out civil society and the
problem is on the right if we don't
watch ourselves we're gonna squeeze that
as well and so what we had to do is go
back and open up civil society which
means re limit government so that civil
society can get rightful place as the
center of our society center of our
community and so civil society is a big
term its family its community its church
its it's everything it's the space
between ourselves and our government
where we live our lies where we use our
minds to practice our vocations to help
others and to go through the the
messiness of life where we enjoy being
human and
that is getting crowded out ever so much
because of a liberalism because of
progressivism because of the the Hegel
Weber this ministry of state crap you
know kind of seeped into our public
policy are you trying to seduce me
speaker so with relativism so we've got
a challenge as conservatives to go back
and re litigate and we hope in this
space the antidote is civil society so I
mean we all have our roles we play sure
for us it's real limit government that's
why I believe in the the agenda the
better way that we put through which was
to do just that to try and open this
space back up as much as we possibly can
so that those antibodies can come back
and we can regrow the the right stuff so
you know I warned you that there was an
elephant in the room that we couldn't
avoid talking about but we don't have to
dwell on it my own personal view is that
uh you know President Trump is not the
cause of all of our problems but there
are a lot of aspects of his presidency
there are symptoms of a lot of our
problems as I try to keep telling people
on the resistance sort of left Donald
Trump is not Hitler Hitler could have
repealed Obamacare and that is really
good it's funny cause it's true um you
can look it up and but when you say that
you know we have to push things back to
civil society and I agree with that
entirely on a the more you give people a
sense that they actually have power over
their own lives and that they know the
names of the powers that be rather than
as abstractions the better off our
democracy will be and you'll still have
cultural wars but the winners will have
to look the losers in the eye he's gonna
see them at the kids soccer game and
everything else so I agree with all of
that but when you have a present United
States who comes along who says and I
will say in sort of populist nationalist
right-wing terms something that was said
about Barack Obama as well I alone can
fix it yeah right this idea that a
single person as an expression of the
people has the will and the power you
know the the rhetoric of conservatives
that we grew up
reading was that the government was too
powerful that it was filled with too
many smart people want a medal too much
the rhetoric of the current president is
that the government was too weak and too
stupid which is a significant departure
from normal conservative rhetoric if
we're gonna have these arguments how do
we deal with some of the arguments that
we get coming up yeah I mean so I would
use different arguments if I were in
that job but what can I do is Speaker
the house or a guy in Congress passed
the policies that actually advanced our
principles show the principles again
work so that we can have fresh evidence
of our principles but more importantly
advance what we believe is real limiting
government take a look at the fact that
we got 17 very important regulatory
reform bills in law which real emmitt
the administrative state take a look at
you know the economic agenda the
national security agenda the things that
we all believe in so that a we have
evidence that our principals put into
policies work we have new evidence of
that that's important to re win and
relitigate these debates but also I
think it's important that we kind of
return power back to you know
individuals and communities which is
what our agenda is doing irrespective of
populist rhetoric that's out there so
but there is this so I agree with you I
like Edmund Burke sittings that examples
the school of mankind and he'll learn it
no other sometimes you have to show
people you can't rest help you a little
petunia and so but at the same time you
know you alluded to this earlier about
how we used to think identity politics
is fundamentally left-wing yeah right
and now there are big chunks of the of
the sort of common section right for one
of a better term who are practicing a
kind of identity politics if you have
white people yeah and it takes different
forms many of them I think pernicious
some just sort of silly what can and
should we do to actually push back on it
yeah I think just a you know actually do
everything you can to defeat it they all
try tis
whatever we don't know what the
alt-right was until I had a primary
right on any claim to be from the
alt-right
these things give rides with different
labels but it is that right and it is
identity politics it's antithetical to
what we believe and it's a hijacking of
our terms it's like the progressives
hijacked the word liberalism you know
the blood and soil nationalists of the
alt-right of hijack things like Western
civilization right and so we have to go
back and fight for our ground and agree
when these ideas and marginalize these
guys as best we can to the corners and
show that these not only the problem we
have is there's fresh evidence that that
stuff works mm-hmm and like I said what
political II politically politically it
works when you when you throw 21st
century technology on there and then
people can make money doing it right
that is a problem so we have to do a
better job and this is where I wish I
had better answers this is what I look
forward to having some time to think
about this stuff yeah how do we get the
core back how do we get back classical
liberalism properly understood in the
21st century
so that we can relegate this stuff to
the ash heap it belongs to but
unfortunately they actually kind of
keeps coming back and growing right
let's just get the ash heap growing so
it's on the a sheet that's the way look
at this stuff but you know I I just
think the right have there are there are
people who they don't believe in
classical liberalism if they believe in
this kind of white identity politics
right that is not conservatism that is
that is racism that is nationalism that
is that is not what we believe in that
is not the founding vision that is not
the founders creed that is not natural
rights that is not natural law so what
do we have to do we have to go back and
reteach and relitigate and relearn and
re expose people to these concepts the
way I see it I would also just for the
sake of argument an absolutely argument
just to assert it I say that one of the
reasons you get this is because of the
erosion of civil society yes that when
absolutely people no longer feel that
the communities that they live in our
actual communities where they're
respected or loved or welcomed or
whatever they retreat to virtual
communities which are not remotely as
satisfying and the problem with places
like Facebook
which has a lot of great things going
forward it's great for keeping up with
old friends it's not great for creating
new communities well you can make money
off of all the bad stuff like money off
of all the dark emotions within people
but you also get people telling you
rather than telling disagreeing with you
you you self-select and find people who
already agree with everything you're
doing and actually encourage you to
spiral out any further we're just
talking about this in the car on the way
over here the math is part of our enemy
right now what is that it's algorithms
on websites and cable news that are
basically saying in order to survive
this business model hits clicks and
ratings you better project back to
people what they want right so you have
these algorithms that are basically
holding us off into our corners into our
enclaves seeing the other side is the
enemy and there goes civility and civil
society that is a huge challenge that we
have all the more reason why we're gonna
have to come up with better ways of
rebranding reclaiming and reselling and
retelling the story of natural law
natural rights this beautiful thing that
we had you call it the miracle
absolutely that's this and I promise to
read the important things you buy it a
little busy with session but um we've
got it we've got to go back and reclaim
this ground and and I believe we can
because what I we have insecure
conservatives who are insecure about our
beliefs that they only think certain
people who are like them can have a
capacity of believing this thing right
what I learned from jack kemp in my
early 20s is you can go on proselytize
democratic capitalism free enterprise
especially in areas where they've never
equated it and you get new converts all
the time right that's secure
conservatism right that is that is
something that we where we can't wait to
show these ideas especially with people
who haven't been acquainted with them
that is not what insecure conservatives
all right national populist blood and
soil people that's what not is not what
they think they think only people like
me could possibly grasp these contests
or agree with me and then you've got
this this these these industries going
through this transformation
using algorithms this pumping stuff back
to people what they what they want to
hear and this is the challenge we have
in front of us right so one of these it
does make sense someone wrote a book
about that and I know one of the things
I always read impress upon people is
that one of most radical things the
founding fathers did in the Constitution
never gets taught as being particularly
important or interesting which was
getting rid of titles and nobility and
which were aristocracy in titles of
nobility and royalty and all that kind
of thing were standard fare for 10,000
years after the Agricultural Revolution
that's the one of the first forms of
identity politics it says that simply by
accident of birth some people are more
deserving or more special than other
people right and what America did was
say no no everyone's gonna start out
sort of with a clean slate
yeah and so I think that that stuff is
hugely important but I think what's more
important is actually teaching people a
sense of gratitude for how good we have
right cuz the opposite of gratitude
which is what we teach people today
entitlement is entitlement and
resentment right and which brings me of
course to Millennials damn kids and we
now have I don't have the numbers in
front of me but you know we now have
unprecedented numbers of people who say
that socialism is preferable yeah we
have this congresswoman who just won in
she's not in Congress yet well it's soon
to be that's right right yeah well the
New Republic has already told me that
she's gonna save the world oh yeah but
democratic socialism when Democrats with
progressivism is too conservative and
moderate that's my credit socialism now
that's the hip and cool thing um
do the members of because one of the
reasons why this emerges is that the
memory of the Cold War is gone right and
we don't teach people to be grateful for
the incredible prosperity that we have
and some people say oh that looks pretty
cool because yeah in part cuz that's
that's sort of how our brains are
actually wired do the members of your
caucus have the vocabulary to talk about
socialism not in the context of rivers
of blood and Stalin but actually talk
about it on the terms that that younger
people today are thinking about it
which members of my caucus you're
referring to mostly louie gohmert
so i am not gonna touch that i didn't
figure would so i i think yeah for the
most part yes for the most part yes but
what I worry about is we came of age
when that was a fresh lesson and we all
were steeped in it and now we're victims
of our success and we got lazy and and
it's not being taught anymore then you
have the progressives pushing constantly
in building you know the whole life for
Julia I think that's a great example I
forgot about that until I saw referenced
about in your book that I'm really
excited about reading in the future so
the progressives are out there pushing
the other side which is emotionally
attractive its emotionally appealing and
we conservative classical liberals took
it all for granted that are not real
earning these lessons and then you take
a look at our educational system and
it's just not good it's just not going
our way again
why we need to decentralize why we need
civil society why we need school choice
you know why we need all these things to
go back and real it again it and how our
new challenge is is the 21st century
digital age we're in which which is
which makes it easier for the for the
for the for the for us to revert back to
our mean in society and not have this
beautiful exceptional miracle read
championed which is what we all got to
go do switching gears a little bit it
seems to me that one of the things that
makes Supreme Court fights so ugly and
to borrow a term from social science so
stupid is how is because we've invested
in the Supreme Court powers and it
shouldn't yeah right if if if one of
nine justices basically has more power
than Congress to do all sorts of things
of course we're gonna treat it as a
legislative branch and resource when to
spend money on it like it's a political
camp
yeah right do you think that that
judge Cavanaugh is about to go home
justice do you think that with that
appointment that we're gonna see
Democrats and Republicans sort of go
back to where it's supposed to be and
have these fights in the legislative in
the elected politics arena rather than
use the court it can't look like a
campaign or oh I'm saying is are we
gonna let's say for the sake of argument
that we get judge Kavanagh and then and
let's say for the sake of ardent the
Supreme Court actually starts not
legislating from the bench but actually
throwing bringing things back to the
elected or whatever on anything right
how do you think that's gonna change
politics no so I think so too your
second is your previous question I think
our members are getting there far better
than where we were before
I think our majority was soft on
philosophy in the early 2000s lost or
majority in some ways deservedly so
and I think a lot of us I started this
thing called young guns with Kevin and
Eric and that was to go back and find
conservatives who could make us a more
conservative majority different kinds of
people arrived at conservatives and they
arrived at it through pragmatism as a
businessperson or a dentist or a think
tank ER that but we all are far more
acquainted with these ideas so the
caucus is better than now than it was in
the old days this these judge fights
bring that to arise and for instance a
lot of the agenda we ran on a lot of it
was about article one versus the other
articles a lot of it was about the
separation of powers and we have a long
ways to go to get back from where the
progressive era took us right but we're
at least acknowledging it and going down
that path
I hired new legislative directors and
the legislative counsel's office to make
sure we write really tight statues so we
don't give the executive branch a bunch
of leeway I just finished negotiating
Cepheus reform to make sure that this
and future administration's don't have
all this discretion to regulate the
economy so we are more attuned to this
than we were before and these judicial
fights clearly put us in that area and
those judicial fights yes I mean he's
probably gonna pass what what 51 52 53
votes well my guess is one
red state Democrats probably three
follow probably how this thing goes I
think he's gonna get in but twenty years
ago he probably would have gotten sixty
five seventy votes so yes we're back to
tribalism yes we're back to the
progressives are more progressive and
conservatives are what we just described
we're gonna have this but what what the
lesson comes out of this is judicial
activism versus strict constructionism
so at least we're back to arguing about
the Constitution ten years ago we didn't
really have those arguments we do now if
anyone had Sophia's reform and Paul Ryan
bingo congratulations so one last
question and then we have time for just
two questions from the audience and I
will rule with a iron fist about who
gets picked so one of my P's these days
because some I'm so cool is about
article one supremacy I'm more and more
of a Congress as not to if they're not
go week well branches right yeah right
Congress is actually you know people say
well foreign policy is completely the
president's well yeah you guys get to
know no you know declare war which is a
exactly a trivial part of foreign policy
and and you pay for this thing called
the military so but it seems to me that
one of the reasons why we're at one of
the reasons why a politician on the
right or the left can come forward and a
campaign on I alone can fix it right or
as I think Barack Obama put it people of
Earth stop your bickering I'm Barack
Obama and I'm here to help but if we is
that because Congress has over the
century over the last century outsourced
absolutely created basically a fourth
branch of government aid your way right
yes so personally whatever I know you
have feelings about trade we don't to
get too deep in the weeds on that but
the president is not supposed to have
this kind of power on trade you are
basis yeah right
how goes the process of the project of
clawing back the power that the founding
fathers actually wanted well trade is
where we have the most work to do yeah
because about a hundred years ago they
passed
laws that give so much discretion and
what presidents gonna reduce their power
right when you put a bill like that on
their desk so you had to go with
different routes this is a project
that's gonna take a long time but we
have been serious about that first of
all one of the first bills I put on the
floor in this session was we called the
reins act major rules and regulations
that was in my Paul Ryan bingo major
rules regulations come back to Congress
for a final voter approval remember
before they go into effect so that we
have final say uh say-so on laws that to
me is one of the most important things
we can do to rein in the administrative
state unelected bureaucracies writing
laws very very important one of the
first things we did I guarantee you
Chuck Schumer will filibuster this to
the day he dies that is obviously so
what frustrates us in the house 800
bills we've passed about 550 of them
sitting in the Senate a lot of those
first article 1 bills that we passed are
sitting over there because of the
filibuster and that's a frustration for
us in the house so what do we do we make
sure we write smart appropriation bills
what do we do we write a Russia
sanctions bill that we bring to the
floor that gets huge vote count so that
the president is no choice but to sign
it we did that about a year ago what do
we do we make sure that the way we draft
our laws we write them very tightly
because we know if Chevron's gotten out
of control and we don't want the
administrative state no matter who is
present and our experience off of the
Obama experiences we better write these
things really tightly right so we do
that we do basically the reins that kind
of a thing in the way we write statues
now so we're very cognizant of this and
then we want to make sure that that
Mitch who's done a very good job on this
gets really good judges on the bench to
try and reverse this trend so don't
think that this is not on the front of
our minds it is we are legislating this
way but we need to have a bigger vote
count in the Senate to actually get
these things on the President signed
into law and the president does support
these bills where we do have an issue is
on trade the president as all previous
presidents in our lifetimes has had a
lot of discretion on trade
I wrote the TPA law the TPA law was one
example
Rison
where we got more legislative power into
the trade space not nearly as much as
we'd like but we clawed back a lot from
the administration on trade so we're
making progress it's not all bait as
fast as we'd like
okay so first question I'm supposed to
pick people I recognized for fear of
terrible things going on but I'll go
with this guy in the front because it's
easy please wait for the mic and we
actually only have time for one question
okay oh my gosh pressure on you this
better be good yeah and yeah and blue
socks sandals yes please make your
statement in the form of questions do
you gentlemen view the Federal Reserve
as the center of power that should be
reined in yeah I mean I'm a big believer
in a fixed rule so I mean I can go on
and on I believe I believe you do want
to keep the Fed I do I do believe in
independence in the Fed I do believe in
auditing I do believe in having clear
books and I do believe we should have a
standard a fixed rule that we govern the
Federal Reserve on and the
humphrey-hawkins law gives the Fed first
of all it puts into the feds statue the
bogus I won't get into the Phillips
curve puts into it the wrong I'm going
go okay scratch my itch the Fed should
have explicit rules should have an
explicit rule and should govern itself
by that and there should be made clear
that takes away that that gets us off of
fiat money onto a fixed standard that is
a reliable source of value where we know
exactly what our money is so that we
cannot have the basement by the Federal
Reserve which takes away our livelihoods
so but but but the last thing I want to
do is get politicians involved in
meddling with interest rates in the
Federal Reserve so you want to make sure
that you keep this thing away from
political interference and meddling and
this is not a Vladimir Putin statement
away from political interference and
meddling but have a standard that is
objective that is adhered to in
transparent so that we're getting away
from the fee
money days and we're not the basing our
currency in the future and as the
world's reserve currency this is an
exorbitant privilege that we we could
abuse if we don't watch ourselves we
passed this bill as well we actually
passed so so bill huizinga from the
Financial Services Committee along with
jeb Hensarling have passed legislation a
bill that says the Fed has to put out
this kind of rule and has more
transparency so the house is actually
acted on these rules rewriting the
humphrey-hawkins which is the statute
that governs the Fed I can guarantee you
chuck filled Chuck filibuster eatable
Schumer this bill I see a hashtag for me
anyway I want to thank the speaker he's
been very very tight time we wanted to
have a longer conversation but we this
is what we could work out because of
really my pressing schedule and and I
one thing I do ask is that everybody
stay in their seats are where they are
until the the speaker goes and then I
will talk for another hour and a half on
but no but I want to thank everybody
join me and making sure we all read his
book all right all right thanks thank
you yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]